12h15 la grande bousculade le maire de
paris ga de pénétrer dans le forum par
la porte berger 4 septembre 1979
le forum des halles à paris est
inaugurée après quinze années de travaux
et de polémiques
un nouveau temple de la consommation -
très loin de l'atmosphère des années 50
pendant plusieurs siècles les halles
abritait le ventre de paris
mais en 1969 le marché devenu trop
étroit et insalubres et délocalisé à
rungis
place alors à la rénovation du quartier
des halles cher au gouvernement de
l'époque on ne reconnaît plus que
l'église saint-eustache
sur ce plan définitif du quartier des
halles trois éléments essentiels
un grand espace qui doit être planté en
sous sol un espace qualifié d' un mot
rom forum est en dessous encore la
station du rer le métro express régional
raccordé à la ligne de show très vite
les travaux de la gare rer commandes à
l'extérieur en revanche la valse des
projets architecturaux ralenti
l'aménagement du trou d air en 1976 le
président valéry giscard d'estaing donne
enfin son feu vert à un projet commun de
4 ap l'espagnol ricardo beau fils en
faisait partie
c'est un bon plongée qu'il est sur le
fil et qu'il faut travailler petit à
petit détail par détail si on veut le
transformer en une véritable star
l'année suivante en 1977 la station rer
de châtelet les halles est déjà terminée
véritable plaque tournante du réseau
express régional cette station est la
plus grande du monde
pendant ce temps-là nouveau
rebondissement à l'extérieur le maire de
paris jacques chirac écarte finalement
le projet beau fils chirac choisi alors
un nouvel architecte et présente son
projet voté par le conseil de paris en
un an plus tard le forum des halles
ouvre ses portes mais le réaménagement
du site ne sera complètement achevée
qu'en 1985 et les avis étaient mitigés
on est dégoûtés
chaque fois ça se monte puis c'est de
plus en plus l'air le forum des halles
devient pourtant l'une des places
commerciales les plus prisés de la
capitale devenu aujourd'hui canopée elle
attire plus de cent cinquante mille
visiteurs chaque jour
[Musique]